listen guys a bunch of you live a
healthy lifestyle bunch you want to lose
weight get in shape for your ladies or
your man whatever you're into you have
no idea what you're doing though you go
to the gym you eat right but you're just
guessing you might use your watch to
calculate things but you don't got whoop
I'm talking about whoop is the
performance tool to help you get your
body right you get the whoop strap which
is a heart rate monitor that measures
your heart rate ready
100 times per second 24/7 you can charge
it while you wear it super easy
what does whoop do people always ask me
what's whoop do measure recovery looks
at your heart rate you get recovery
score so you know exactly how hard you
can push it from day to day your strain
how many college did you really burn how
many miles did you go how long did you
run they check out your workout to
eighty plus your sleep Mars your heart
rate throughout your sleep REM deep
sleep light sleep sleep cycles it checks
all that so you have the insights to
know exactly what you're doing with your
workouts what you can out your rest
everything there's nothing that monitors
your workout your lifestyle better than
woop and woop has provided you guys $30
off their purchase with the code fighter
just go to whoop calm that's WH go P
calm use the code fighter at checkout
and save $30 and optimize the way you
train if you fall in the silver October
all the boys the Chrysler segura re
Brogan they're all calculating their
work out through woop I rock whoop when
I hike and running doing whatever I do
doubt the day it's a lifestyle for me go
to whoop calm promo code is fighter app
check out come on man let's do this
come on bro that's what I say now so
like a lot of times like if I'm gonna
have sex I go no prisoners let's do oh
you know I say what before I'm about the
bus nothing oh let's ride really man
that's good like that I go this is for
Brandon what about this let's go let's
go ha ha mommy I say that sometimes no
you don't yep I sometimes I go my dick
is barfy
something I want to sorry it's Monday
that's uh you know I'm very odd cast
it's it's it's [ __ ] rock Monday and
whenever it's got a heart Bachman now
it's [ __ ] rock no guess a card come on
you can say Rock [ __ ] Monday but but
that means our I like [ __ ] rock come a
because we're rock well I say Rock [ __ ]
because we're rockin with our [ __ ] out
o [ __ ] our rock so it's [ __ ] rock
Monday now when people say I'm all [ __ ]
have you ever meet somebody who's like
kind of like sophisticated person they
go I'm almost in your podcast and I go
not for you I like only get a judges if
we do yeah like what if [ __ ] I am to
my fans like you know cuz cuz I'm
talking about being [ __ ] rock Monday I
just talked about my dick bar sure
that's you dude but that's you I'm 5050
[ __ ] took Olivia truth especially
with some woman who sophisticated a
friend like a wife of a friend of mine
I'll be like no not for you no no you
can't listen to that not for you no you
do you read a lot of books are you sit
also for you maybe they need it well you
know what then they listen to it they're
like yeah a lot of people laughs I go
who's the thick kid almost like it's day
why I don't know you hear them say that
no dude you missed out on Philly bro
that's one of the bad news guys one of
the best cities in the world use guys
yeah how about the history in Phil
abbess only home to the Liberty Bell uh
saw the Liberty Bell yeah small and you
think small anything cracked
yep big old he's all been drank wounds
crib no Ben Franklin used to [ __ ] that's
right they the rumor was four to six
women a day is that right I don't
believe that but I don't believe a real
rat contour he was a very he loved women
when he'd go to Paris he was the talk of
the town he could speak French he was
just like oh yeah five nine I think to
some to twenty but that was vegetarian
and then that vegetarian yep there was a
lot of vegetarian facts they live on
carbs but he was vegetarian then he was
on that he was on this using this on his
way to Paris and they were cooking cod
and he was like that Cod they caught
these cotton they were cooking it in
butter
and he was like holy [ __ ] I smell dying
to eat it and then they cut a cot open
and there are a bunch of there was a
couple bunch of fish in the cod stomach
and he went what like no the car to eat
and a bunch of oh yeah hold up fish so
he goes he goes like this he was but
wait a minute
if I eat cod I'm saving fish so in a way
eating cod might be killing a fish but
I'm saving a bunch of smaller fish so
interesting so he justified it news
crazy you know that's smart I thought
that well he just you know silly but he
was basically saying you can justify
anything so he ate the [ __ ] out under
God and stop being a goddamn okay it was
cool to see man I I went to this place I
wish you were there dude I went to this
shoe place called suplex and so it's
just like Philly guys who run it you
know we're all sneakers but Philly they
the block they knew the eyes would use
guys okay cool the town old-school took
us under their wing yeah they're like
where'd you eat I went I went to Geno's
and Patrick Tuohey said [ __ ] that play
no we go up there they take us we just
place called Angelo's your boy Bradley
Cooper he's from Philly yeah yeah that's
his spot yeah shuts it down when he goes
it's the only place he when he goes to
the bow so they make all the food for
the Philadelphia Eagles that we met the
owner bring up the picture of all of us
chin
we met the at Angelo's we met the only
real Italian Italian dude gets up at he
lives in Jersey not far yeah gets up at
3:00 in the morning as a bread for the
retina whole whole day and he has this I
guess he has this bread maker and here
talked about the passion the bread and I
guess there's some pizzas going out the
door because they make like Philly
cheesesteaks pita and ridiculous the
best food I've ever had in my life
and he's gone out the door and he's
doing here the pits and the crust is
like kind of burnt underneath that's all
you guys that's all of us that's our
crew that's the Philly crew there oh
that's great there's the crew [ __ ] I
could live in that city it was so nice
but the owner the soul would go out with
the pizzas let me see it no no just give
me this give me this gift no no no no no
no salt everything because he said the
the the the maker of the oven was
cooking the bread too much yeah that's
how detailed it so my grandfather who's
hotter percent Sicilian from Brooklyn
same same animal yeah my gram
we'd walk into a [ __ ] restaurant I'm
not joking he'd go like this he'd look
at the brightening we're not going here
yeah we'd have to turn around he was a
maniac good the Italians couldn't be
more insane about food I'm telling you
that some of the best food we've ever
had and then I made pizza
Lorenzo's and the dough man it was the
most I could have just ate the dough
probably because he'll I made it myself
it's the water it's the water it's the
type of flour they make it's it's a
whole deal it's a whole thing that it
was nice be they don't play around bread
is everything pasta bread the way the
way specifically well that's me with
Lorenzo look at that well his dad
Lorenzo but he owns all yes the son now
I just listened to to our interview with
Sammy the bull Gravano I listen to it
too pretty interesting I was good after
45 yeah for me I grow so pogs as well
not at all you know for me like he was
he was like growing up in New York City
when when there was the ravenite Club
where John Gotti and Little Italy we
used to go either place called Cafe
Sorrento right near it and you see those
guys I never saw a Gravano and I never
saw John Gotti but you saw those guys
the Goodfellas they were the good fella
and he liked what he was saying which
was John Gotti broke all the rules he
started wearing Briony suits and being
like a movie star they call him the
Teflon Don and Sammy the bull was like
were a secret society what the [ __ ] is
he this is my problem though Sammy the
bull who's ultimates right he's the term
for rat ultimates not really though he
but that's the thing you watch this and
it's makes it seem like it was but he
was hidden Sammy the bull was the guy
who was always he was the guy in the
background he was the killer
he was really organized it was a kill
yeah he was his Aguirre terrible human
being
yeah awful oh no oh no you wanna tease
like I I grew up around these guys I
could tell you dude
me and Stevie blue eyes your time like
Stevie's goes here watch this on the
plane some guy well thanks Stevie themes
would be some piss [ __ ] watch it's
fantastic the case pretty closely like I
remember in New York I remember
everything that happened I think a lot
of Gotti Gotti was God he was the one
who's getting pinched yeah I mean Sam
Sammy Sammy was a real gangster like in
other words oh he's wrong but he lived
and died by gaudí
John Gotti was he made his son a capo
which
you know he didn't work his way up there
was all these all these rules he kinda
broke and he became he brought them
front and center where he became a
celebrity yeah as a criminal and these
guys were like the real guys will I be
lovin [ __ ] yeah I remember even my
grandfather grew up around these guys in
Brooklyn yeah and my grandfather's
father helped a lot of these guys not
not crime wise but ladies guys allow
these guys were immigrants so their
fathers came over yeah any peak he had a
spaghetti sauce that factory so he'd
give them work yeah how about so when
there were strikes my grandfather's
trucks were the first ones allowed on
the docks yeah so if you didn't know it
my my godfather red manager Mele he was
a real tough guy he was a long short he
was vice-president Longshoremen's Union
yes so so so so there were rules there
were very specific rules and one of the
things that they would say is that you
never saw these guys you never knew you
never [ __ ] knew what they were I
remember that you never had my grandma
my mother grew up around these guys you
don't want the attention
never in what the term and family like
it was all about family and they
obviously don't [ __ ] around with them
I'm not saying they were good guys but
there was a bear you are know there was
there were there were very specific
rules with the attack they only kill
each other like an effective family
wives remember when he said if you with
your hold my brains all right but that's
why the cartels like with with the Mafia
they had so many legitimate businesses
member when he said if you were with
your wife or your kid I wasn't gonna
kill you that's true they never did that
it was but it was considered very very
bad and in fact when John Gotti
was turning I remembered I think I got
this right
for the first time Sammy the bull and
his guys tried to kill one of Gotti's
family members I think it was his might
have been sauna or what it's custom
public and that was I remember in the
news they were going to big yeah that's
that's what they've never done that this
is desperation time so it was a boy yeah
you Peter said it's super interests on
YouTube if here's Sammy talked about
though he goes you know we weren't
supposed to talk about it when supposed
to be on the news and he goes in you
definitely a snitch I each other and
then John brings me in and was like hey
so they're the the DA's gonna make you
have to be the horrible guy you have to
take the fall and Jake about [ __ ] he's
like that's what you want to do you want
to give me up yeah so he said he left
that meeting was like oh [ __ ] this I'm
giving him up yeah and back in the day
he said I would have killed I would have
killed John
my heart was broken because they were so
close I saw the London the only time I
saw real mobsters together I was it was
a construction site in New York on like
6th Avenue and I don't know 34th Street
or something like that and I see these
it was so interesting every one of them
couldn't have been thicker could have
been stronger they looked again like out
of a movie real tough guys and they were
just all talking and laughing with these
be and it was so [ __ ] javi we were in
Boston we went to that place our friend
goes be cool here if you see girls don't
be [ __ ] harm I'm like Weissach well
this is owned by I remember those guys
clocked you know man you walked into
these they were as tough looking as it
gets they were obviously just connected
yeah yeah but they saw you and knew who
you were because you probably fight what
they watch fighting they bet this was
but right after you've been fighting so
Y can went mama me yeah they clocked you
it I was just like Jesus it was very
interesting on a boys couple meatballs
for you guys alright hey hey you die hey
you [ __ ] hey you [ __ ] loved a god
man watch you Pete mind your P's and Q's
you get your card marked alright you're
gonna get you cut it is interesting in
it yeah the old discipline there was a
the real discipline among the Italians
and that's why they ran the [ __ ] show
have you ever seen the the John Gotti I
think it was on history or maybe forget
a me there's the son the son who he got
pinched right did some time here yeah he
got out in there John Gotti they have
the video of him going in prison cuz
he's like you know I I went away my kids
were like two three four and the inside
[ __ ] I go away for six years and then I
get out you go away for life he's like I
don't want I don't live this life they
have the video of him going into prison
telling John Gotti senior his dad gone I
don't do this anymore
dude his dad is pissed
oh yeah and he okay he was never a guy
they he didn't want to do it he was
never a guy little pressure arrest the
the the Goodfellas were like this guy
didn't work his way up you just broke a
bit he also didn't want to do it he'll
he's in a [ __ ] black turtleneck they
forgot yeah it's not it's a very rare
guy like Sammy the bull these guys it's
very rare to be a real gangster oppa I
so I don't know about all of them being
sociopaths actually I think I'm in the
bowl I think yeah well I think others
you guys fall into the the life and they
kill they'll kill guys from other
families and stuff like that I didn't
get sociopaths from Sanibel I really
didn't watch one documentary no no I'd
follow this way way before he was always
like considered to be this complete
badass but again there was such a
discipline to it and he was like I don't
know I mean look they're very different
guys different dudes check out Carlo
Gambino's underboss
I think it's Carla gander oh no no I'm
who is the guy was killed his sparks
who's the guy was killed at sparks
warehouse the stake same Valentine's Day
message yeah know who so Sammy the bull
organized the killing of his boss Oh
Paul Castellano was the big bomb yeah
look at customers underboss take a look
at this guy this guy was the real deal
Paul Castellanos knew Paul Castellanos
underboss yeah and they they killed him
yeah hold on no no no I just clicked it
camera this guy's name and know the old
dude this thing yeah I think that's
history Neal yeah look go go to images
yeah look look at images of this guy are
like out of a movie a couple of pictures
of him he was Luciano was the was the
main one who made it when he's younger I
was he's on who made it as a business
because the Italian but he was a chan of
his day he was Jewish on it was the one
who made it as the business and he
always wanted to he he didn't want to
sell drugs yeah he the Italians when
they came here Oh always they never want
to sell drugs they knew end up [ __ ]
them that's right and lucky Luciano's
the guy who never want to sell drugs
I feel like Luciano even though it's an
Italian name was Jewish am I right about
that
no that's Meyer Lansky I'm thinking
tomorrow Lansky sorry okay so did Jewish
the Jewish Mafia's work that karate and
they let anybody else do it and they
invest in real businesses well though
Georgie Luciano's like that he'd be the
Joe Namath of gangsters he had the
[ __ ] probably judge that's that's
what they said about a lot of the
gangsters like the Jewish gangsters
would like they'd make their money but
their kids became doctors and lawyers
and they invested invested yeah
we kept going yeah it doesn't end good
for name one by means I'm sure they're
out there with name name either guess
who it's ended up well it work ends it
ends worse and it's better for fighters
and better for boxers than it does for
gangsters gangsters are what well that
was the guy who said the 47 the 50 most
the highest earners that the guys who
made the most money in the mob they went
through the list of 50 and this guy was
talking about that the best gangsters
the ones that got away with it forever
47 are dead or in jail
I mean they can't be in the real saying
it was worth I think it's around two
billion dollars yeah you know how it is
you know it's gonna happen I mean Sammy
the bull did for 22 years the most
depressing part to me is when like when
you watch Goodfellas obviously it's
loosely based off gang stuff when
they're going through and he's going the
restaurant he's like a hot chicks and
doing the thing they're having fun
there's slick zoot suits and yeah the
best restaurants the hottest chicks the
cars and then when they get older and it
shows them just like oh like well that
but think about like what it's like when
you're a young man and you got all your
boys and you're not only doing what you
want this you gotta win it for a while
it's working for a while I bet it's
you're running as a crew yes you're
running as a crew you're [ __ ] doing
whatever you want shanks ugly right
everybody loves you everybody loves you
you get any girl you you're making money
you're a gangster you're 28 or whatever
the world and then of course somebody
gets pinched and they're looking at
their now they're from now you guys are
in your 40s and somebody's somebody's
today the FBI built a whole case and
they go to to your friends and they go
yeah you guys have been friends for 20
years you're brothers I know listen now
you're gonna go to jail ready for this
for a hundred years
yeah a hundred you'll never see your
kids really and that's what Sammy said
so yeah exactly sue said that they made
it so like it possible if you get caught
three can you be so many your life's
over
so guys quit [ __ ] around for once and
there are guys that took the floor there
are a lot of guys that went [ __ ] you Amy
had a great point similar jobs are law
to get sent a lot of guys who get put
away and then there why they to have
kids and wives and stuff and they're the
the guys from the same mafias we go
their house [ __ ] their wife take their
money
never and they're like this is this sue
you're going away 30 to 40 years for it
so traditionally [ __ ] your wife
visually that's why the Italians you
never did that
that's why traditionally if you if you
were caught [ __ ] not supporting the
family or taking the guy's wife you were
[ __ ] you you can get killed for that
yeah you could that and that's exactly
why those rules started to crumble and
one of the things that did an article on
believe it or not he said what killed a
lot of the Italian mafia was the
breakdown of family values was the
breakdown of this medical he [ __ ] said
look as a southern Italian growing up
with my people like my grandfather I can
tell you that and my mother of course I
can tell you that discipline Oh like
doing certain things there were just
certain things that you you just did and
my grandfather like as a manual raised
as a woman you were raised with very
specific rules that you never broke it's
that old country old-school mentality
Lindo aren't they a lot of times yeah
but make no mistake the Italians a lot
of people realize the Italians are very
conservative people their culture is
incredibly conservative especially the
sort of the South very conservative and
always work yeah my fish it's crazy man
it's crazy but drugs man when drugs came
in Lucky Luciano never wanted to do it
drugs walked everything because and now
you're looking at cuz you know gambling
running rackets you know prostitution
you do a five-year stretch we'll stop
[ __ ] heroin you're gonna wait forever
cocaine yeah and then you got to kill
people because now it's meth the big
things meth you know it stopped a lot of
the killing though with them up it's
just cameras back in the seventies
eighties nineties mob guy you you
cameras everywhere cameras ring ring on
that doors everybody they seize
everything you can do [ __ ] now you can't
do those spectacular hits they just fell
out now let's see if we're being watched
everywhere well in Chicago you can go to
where that uh it might be in the state
Valentine's Day met when the or nowhere
uh alcohol you can go to the where they
where his henchmen staked out to shoot
underneath is a pizza place one of the
best pizza place Chicago they come in
like these [ __ ] bowls pizza was all
right more like a casserole to me but
they had good bread we can't go there
and see where they staked out to kill
it's pretty cool
yeah pretty well yeah people are
obsessed with that mafia [ __ ] you're not
into it you bother yourself yeah but I'm
not as into it as you guys are so you
know the Yakuza in Japan course so do
you know that most of the top guys in
the Cosa are from Korea correct
did you know that I did know that
because well there is a little tattoo
from their neck to the toes
yeah look badass T right oh dude pretty
cool I saw some of those guys in
Shinjuku I remember being like a young
man I was looking at this I was like why
is that
Japanese guy so [ __ ] thick just like
in a suit and I think one of the reasons
why people are in love with mafia and
biker gangs and that in fighters because
you know that they're paying a different
price than the rest of the world to live
that life huh yeah look at those dudes
again the male's just fat with titties a
lot of them are chubby yeah yeah why not
yeah they will kill you they're badass
tattoos that's how you talk watch your
watch your attitude that's a badass dude
that's a bad mother [ __ ] tattoo yeah
if you're gonna get tattoo is holy [ __ ]
takes way too long
dude it don't be surprised if I Yakuza
my back out that crews so sick I bet
that takes forever dude your cuz I now
well that white guy looks ridiculous
look at home that could be you Brian I
want that too he's got pierced nips
that's a commitment dude it's a
commitment I don't know it's a lot in
prison yeah that's how they tell you
right by all your tattoos I thought a
what gang you're affiliated with yeah a
few never got that there's no muff you
know why who's vicars can be identified
exactly makes sense
exactly you should be done fight by your
shooter I like I love tattoos yep
they're done right I love them Wow
I want to wear that you and I should be
wearing those guys look like so is the
cops the cops made those [ __ ] guys
stand like that that's what they did
that's exactly what those cops earlier
this show about the it's uh no those
guys are standing there in front that's
a police line on my friend that's
exactly what that is look at that dude
with the glasses
enjoy that [ __ ] with those guys [ __ ]
with that guy with it with the shades
you you [ __ ] with cocky
I don't like to even tell you I don't
have been Austra I don't like the way
you were talking about the closet
monster today the Christos a little out
of line and there are out of shape of
town in fat guys but they're not top
guys they're not beating people up with
their hands like like they have guns I
was like well I'm just gonna run a mile
it's yet the other side you're not
catching me hey bro
alright hey we gotta take a minute I
gotta educate him take him in everything
hey Brennan yeah man from Aurora let's
find something there you could be at the
bottom of the ocean yeah something funny
delicate nothing that I did you could be
at the bottom of the ocean
the deepest part where them lantern fish
live in a sealed [ __ ] in a sealed
bank vault top of the line [ __ ] you
know look look yeah for what you could
be in that you could be in that okay
you could be in that and you could even
booby trap the walls so they exploded
you touch him ready hold on they would
still get to you eh we still get beer so
I'm gonna breathing cute I wanna
pologize on your behalf oh my gumballs
hungry what is goodbye a bad name no it
just means friend call me friend my
Goomba oh my gumballs out there I won't
apologize for my friend from Aurora cuz
he doesn't understand what he's talking
about doesn't understand where he's
where he's standing so please excuse me
let me apologize let me have a talk with
him I'm gonna have him take back what he
[ __ ] said yeah okay now the problems
Russian mafia all right Russians are
still they're a little too ruthless but
aren't they still around not really what
happened was there a little tomb in
Russia they made the problem is in the
United States they started killing the
dog the grandmother and everything there
was this thing that come and just kill
everybody Russians yeah and you can't do
that to the FBI you can't do that to to
the NYPD police do they look at that
dude and they were like no no you're
nothing that guy's taking some people's
souls from their bodies holy [ __ ] does
he look rough let's enjoy that she got
his Russian tits now he's he's a bad guy
huh notorious Russian mob says he just
wants to go home yeah I don't think so
my man can let you out wow that guy's
scary he's employed yeah oh they do some
dark [ __ ] man yeah you can tell when he
was younger he was a big strong
[ __ ] yeah I bet it is the life
when you're in there man I bet as the
[ __ ] life when you're [ __ ]
chucking and driving with your buddies
robbing [ __ ] yeah getting the hottest
chicks yeah just mind your P's and Q's
so you don't get touched
wasn't a fatal fatal it'll brother yeah
a little I mean giant brother yeah he's
something he's got something to do with
these guys yeah yeah yeah his back well
Fedor back tattoos I guess a nose good
friends with the biggest gangster in the
world yeah yeah wisdom tours he lasted
everybody he's he's the biggest gangster
and the richest man in the world so
enjoy that he's no joke he has some dark
tattoos he's a scary [ __ ] and
trained individual now that would be
ganks I'd be scared of yeah the big fat
guy who makes the calzones in the back
we want to be scared of anybody who's
organized and who's you know oh willing
to look at him look at him
convicted rapist gets parole oh he raped
somebody look at that [ __ ] guy or he
did some raping he's just some a lot of
stuff a ton of Henle like he drinks
really heavily and well that's the least
of his brain yeah that's a scary guy
dude see if you go over to who's the
most gangster and I'm a fighter click oh
it's the forums look at it here's the
black widow death due which means
this one yeah there's some dark [ __ ]
when it comes to his brother yeah these
guys are you don't want to meet I mean
look at him there I just see like in an
alley no I don't want to see him in my
jail cell either he's doing what he
wants going down god that's his [ __ ]
black widow tattoo shows its Christ yep
would someone from who knows their [ __ ]
from Russia broke it down and went over
all of it and really like so dark so he
was he was connected obviously and yeah
what was it was a KBJ out there KGB the
KGB there which is now a different
what's that stand for that was basically
that was their CIA well really no so
yeah so the KGB was was essentially the
Russian CIA but they they did a lot of a
lot of a lot of commit good Spetsnaz but
does the State Security fine the Russian
mafia is referred to it about killing
what were they called
cuz Russia knows Costa Nostra I don't
know what the Russian mafia is called
but they were bad dude yeah so when they
scan you'll see because I've got an
Amsterdam where we tried am I gonna
Hamsterdam some guy was it came in have
fun here and came back names places the
were losing drugs you say but make sure
you're not an [ __ ] there because the
Russian mafia runs all of it yeah yeah
he was there great yeah but if you get
out line you have some problem so a lot
of what happened was this the Russian
mafia had its own underworld and stuff
when the Soviet Union when the wall came
down as it were when Russia no longer
really became communist and it became
sort of a free-for-all a lot of the
people in the KGB who were trained
killers and soldiers and Special Forces
guys then Spetsnaz the KGB a lot of
those guys were like we're an
organization with no job and there's a
shitload of oil up for grabs and mineral
resources and stuff let's just go take
it yeah and so a lot of these so when
when a lot of these guys immigrated at
the United States and they were like
look America is a candy shop and there
was a guy named
Friedman who wrote the read read read
something I'm red mafia or something
like that and I remember he did an
interview said they're coming and a lot
of these guys have their PhDs in math
these guys are very organized they
understand they understand banking and
computers and everything is it's in the
90s so when they came everybody's like
they're gonna take over everything
I remember my father I said Russian
mafia and my father started shaking
scared yeah my dad goes hey guys I don't
think so I said what it means
so you're gonna pit the Russian mafia
against our FBI because the last time I
checked the Russians lost the Cold War
because they couldn't organize because
there wasn't incentive structure taking
on the United States people you think
those guys are gonna fool the FBI in
their country oh there's me he was right
and they came in they started doing they
start shaking down Russian hockey
players they they did all kinds of stuff
with businesses but then they would do
really awful things like kill everybody
you can't do that in this country you're
not allowed to do that because what
would happen is you'd have we were like
wait a minute they killed the
grandmother while she was in her rocking
chair and they killed the dog [ __ ] these
guys you don't want to piss off the our
law enforcement because they're men too
and they see that [ __ ] and they go oh
well you little I 400 okay now you guys
want to take the gloves off all right
here we go
yeah so and and so a lot of those guys
just went to jail they just don't went
to jail it's so fascinating man yeah
yeah and and the tattoos were you had
all these tattoos they were all so easy
to identify you know but I don't know
there was a guy there was a [ __ ] dude
maybe it was a comic who was making fun
of a Russian guy I'd say his story in
New York City comic was making fun of a
Russian guy and he was like kind of a
not a guy and he was with a girl and he
was and the guy was in the thing of this
one you could smoke and he's going like
this and he wasn't laughing and you know
just listening to him and that comic
that night disappeared was in a dumpster
just found a dumpster they killed a [ __ ]
in a dumpster don't [ __ ] around my eyes
don't show Minnesota and all those
health angels are there in the front row
that's why they were I was like I just
got done shooting us sons of anarchy
what's happening fellas is there he said
yeah
they laughed that's pretty cool big boys
yeah big boys outlaws
yeah I told you they're like gods a man
if you want to give me the strip club
the fellas gonna feed the birds
yeah no I'm all set I'm feeding the
birds
well I birds admit their horse was a
member a friend who said our friend goes
I don't I said what's it like to be
around the Hells Angels and he goes
grizzly bears that's all just know
you're with grizzly bears I go what do
you mean because well just yeah I you
know you can go to their chapter they
might be really cool to you but just
remember you're not a [ __ ] grizzly
bear you can be around grizzly bears you
can study them the minute you forget
you're a grizzly bear you're getting
eaten and it's the same thing you might
be good cool the guy in that chapter but
a dude comes from another chapter he
doesn't know you didn't give a [ __ ]
about you so you just got to mind your
P's and Q's and not be too familiar just
not for me in that life now you know
stress that I'd be around that [ __ ] cuz
you be afraid somebody to try to
challenge you or what they all of it
they'll be toxic them mask unit that
testosterone the killing the drugs the
bike bunnies alleged that I like
allegedly a we're Club we're Club
allegedly your organization stop throw
it around I don't like the way you're
talking about I don't like the way
you're [ __ ] I just want to stay on
record don't like the way you're talking
about certain people and those odd
counts and it's not for me but you know
you bit of a snitch this might be
snitching Monday this is snitchy Monday
let me know let me know you're wearing a
[ __ ] adorable pink you got you got a
gold chain and you just running your
mouth I'll tell you what you're a tough
guy you're big tough guy you're not
getting into any group no you're just
too much of a loose lips not for me you
got that flappy tongue huh Chevy that
[ __ ] canary all all [ __ ] squeal
canary can sing let me away for 20 G of
canary can fly that's how you get thrown
out a window yeah that life is here's my
thing too with the Hells Angels you know
let's say they're not do anything but
wait the Hells Angels are suing a young
guy in the sock sack click on that young
jeezy their pseudonym agrees to pay off
Hell's Angel motorcycle club yeah no
[ __ ] for what code you'll have my friend
with merch they tell you this story what
why is he doing that oh look oh he made
that
oh you cannot do the hawser no you
definitely can't do that
dietary my friend who did who did a like
parody of the Hells Angel thing and they
they got you know because they are a
business organization a cell puds of
merchants and they sell tons of merch
what yeah yeah but they're in their logo
and stuff like you can't [ __ ] with your
load kit cannot but the worse than
Disney I cannot [ __ ] now you're not
wearing there my friend made uh made a
shirt made shirt very similar for the
jacket had the same people can't do that
well they got a letter cuz they have
lawyers in the business there's just a
really nice to you at first well they're
just a business so they're just trying
to make offer they're gonna talk to you
they're no different than firing the kid
they've selling merch that's all someone
took this [ __ ]
they get a note he ignores it he ignored
it ignored it was a guy not that big a
deal huh huh dick month later walking
down the street with his buddies no sure
well they found them yeah
stop selling the shirts that's all
please stop selling the sure if the
Hells Angels take the time to get on
their motorcycles all why can't they
have more why you with this friend
walking down son psycho did you get the
letter ah
that's all you've already you've already
did you get the letter I already forced
them to expend physical energy on you
that's already a no-no can you imagine
yeah so thank them thank them for not
thank them for taking the time and give
them your offer to buy them maybe a
couple of drinks as a courtesy offer to
get your girl and offer the Phil their
baby dress them with some gasoline and
have their bikes polished maybe even do
it yourself maybe pull out a funny
motorcycle shirt maybe motivate the boys
you could do that but I don't know if
they're into that maybe pull your
t-shirt off and say can I can it can I
at least polish your fuel tank sir the
[ __ ] are you doing what are you doing
got a letter email was like another B
hey hey hey right a KKK fellas what are
we doing here it's like when my son says
something like I used a word that's a
little too like he's like [ __ ] this at a
time like whoa what my son goes
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
and I want to whoa do you know my son
then - right now it's a little scary but
he loves that movie Apocalypto I think
it's a great movie I do - can't believe
your son loves that movie whenever he
likes like the yeah the way they look in
the know it's an amazing movie
oh so one of the best uh Gila it's so
brutal so after like at the fast word
through the violence he just like to see
him move and like the way they walk and
damn I watch that movie with my father
it's so intense yeah still haven't seen
the Joker still haven't seen the Joker
if I gotta go see it look at that
I just dinner with Mel Gibson did you
hear again yeah good guy talk to him
about this movie he dropped bunch of
names down there um I know hey did you
know did you know what's his name Oh
Jared Leto tried stopping the Joker we
have that as a car he tried stopping the
production of Joker because he thought
by doing Suicide Squad Warner Brothers
guaranteed him to like the spin-off the
Joker so when he found out what King
Phoenix got it what the [ __ ] our as an
agency
yeah flipped out that's crazy man
yeah this might have been this might be
attributed to Jared Leto and it might be
his lawyer so we're doing this yeah I
wonder if Jared Leto Jared Leto wasn't
even in the conversation no he was as
far as like no he was a no no you he had
a no he wasn't in the conversation as
far as Todd Phil right that's one but he
didn't note he thought they were gonna
do the same thing got you and he used in
his contract skin do you know branch off
but now you can't do that know that Todd
Phillips did this they're like well no
we can't do it this get trumped whatever
the [ __ ] would run yeah so it was a
violation maybe of his contract
yeah CAA was probably like her yeah
apparently he really thought that he was
gonna get his own spin-off and he was
already upset with the whole Suicide
Squad situation because they marketed
the film to him as him being the main
villain but when you actually watch the
film he was in it for maybe five ten
minutes
yeah Cara Delevingne character was the
main villain and so he thought he was
gonna get his standalone Joker movie and
then shortly after
philips announced his Joker with Joaquin
Phoenix he was really upset by that
tried to get his team to stop the film
which also is the same team who
represents todd phillips they said no
we're not gonna try to do that and he
ended up leaving CAA for WME shortly
after mm-hmm it's true I find out yeah
yeah my guess is it's such a I didn't
need any ma'am it's such a big role you
know yeah well a lot of people were also
upset with Jared Leto for his antics on
Suicide Squad did you hear about that
he's like sin and wrath yeah he says
Margot Robbie a box with a live rat in a
he sent a box of bullets to Will Smith
and a dead pig to the actors who were in
rehearsals with Suicide Squad
I love Jared Leto too much bro if I'm at
home he sent me a box of bullets or I
think he's very very strange I just like
all right dude I mean I don't know how
much of that is true either by the way
all these rumors I don't believe any of
this stuff but my guess no he did said
that's the stranger stranger stranger
it's just their method acting but also
dude no one thought that would be pure
method acting that's why rumors are that
violence is how was he in this was he
amazing and I people hate him I like
them I like them as Joker and now
compared to walking Phoenix and Heath
Ledger yeah it's a [ __ ] tough go but
I enjoyed him but also you can't really
judge it cuz he's barely there he's
barely in it I thought it looked cool
yeah he's gay he's more of like a
gangster Joker yeah he was definitely
more of a thug in this he's more like a
well like a weird thug whereas Joker was
heard the movie was not good III liked
it
he's a beautiful he's a beautiful young
man Oh beautiful tears Leto timepi I've
seen him in order soup me too and he's
just like he doesn't age but Joaquin
I don't know if you wanna I don't know
if you want to go head-to-head with
Joaquin not an acting looks for sure
yeah but acting what are you doing
Joaquin is one intense dude
but also JLo just cuz Gucci makes it
doesn't mean you have to wear all of it
you know dude Cena's grand no I mean
just has every piece
new really fall collection they have on
its at all on really yeah all at once
he's always been
jerilyn has always been a fashion guy
he's always loved fashion you'll see him
grill does you he is that's good-looking
dude man
let me see yeah yeah they're that
Kutcher working out like a month so
skinny dude look skinny looks pretty
muscular
oh so thin really thin individual very
small been missing his ass off though
yeah III there are people who are much
better but yeah for what he does yeah
he's talented guy man you can't take it
oh he's very talented but don't share
your stomach like that no you can't do
that for really why is he doing it I
don't know but you're not allowed to do
that
let's see why he's doing it there's no
description oh that's a bummer
yeah now you know what I probably do the
same thing about that now here that you
wouldn't you wouldn't because finally
yeah I not I mean I wouldn't care yeah
he's uh response by Gucci I think he's a
vain kid his body doesn't he's got a
good look he looks great him he wears
robes how great is that he showed up to
the the Met Gala that's how he showed up
yeah we'll be back
I could never take the time but he loves
fashion he's just a strange kid he was
like a child actor to men I'm sure he
was I'm sure he was I mean I would love
to have that hair I'd love to have that
hair also is that click on that other
video with him with his shirt off
oh no he's just trying his dick out dude
he's just you know me chicks Linda's
dance after this
he's trying something say to you that to
get girls no no he's fighting some ran
said he was like what's up Germany and
then the hottest
Sloot's in Germany
flutes and Germans dmw how German
salutes came came up [ __ ] knockin
well I thought he's doing a thing for
you and me is he not married with
children he's no he'll stay stuck I've
been a real he he's only 50 keeping it
on his head
really how old is he Jen I look he
tagged ariana grande in this the only
guy who looks better for his age
no the only he beats Frank Grillo in
terms of looking great for his age of
how old is he
47 he's not young no wow grew up in LA
yeah did he tag he ran aground
maybe she's in that movie other place
ActiveX hashtag dad but by the way not
dad by the way sir
how about when he played Chapman what's
his name - Gary Chapman no the guy who
he gained like weight gain so much
weight she says that's a good-looking
guy you know what this is war
come here the album looked that good
[ __ ] he's at hot he's a hot chick but
look he is great now right there's a lot
of town and Oscar
what a nice girls buyers club no it's
phenomenal actor and I celebrate three
things of the Mars dan he's got a saint
chin and he's Danny's rights in the day
I mean the eyes his music is huge
everywhere so enormous
yeah you can't cells up you can't you
can't knock the man he's awesome
I'm just here a little bit of him snot
trying not my kind of guy who I could
hang out with probably I bet me that I
would replace him so fast what would you
do well let's see if state where these
things work this can be tough good go to
where it's good acoustics there you go
get him in the lounge what's this in a
studio those are you actually mess with
pizza which is
I'd say his voice is okay well he's a
rock you know yeah like it's it's it's
it's that's this one he's yelling go to
one yet its stylized right it's not you
know I mean chin it's not somehow it's
like well you can tell just his vocal
control in the notes he wasn't hitting
the actual notes that well that sounds
pretty but he's got that tuning mic they
probably did afterwards yeah keep going
down the one where yells that's what
water you're washing water you're such a
[ __ ] you know that you know you guys
should do you should be on America now
you know but the guy sells millions of
jobs or is sort of other people weren't
good good
like that's not really a you're so
you're so you know you are you know that
tell you [ __ ] are so dazzled by just
glimpse looks if a dude yeah he's you
know what hold on no he checked out
these hallways you've been doing it how
long's he been at your cell you're just
so you're so you're so you are truly a
little gay and it's okay but you get so
excited about your shiny shiny pink hat
and you're like no big no you just like
him cuz he's so good-looking
no do you like him like you don't listen
hey no no no you don't listen to his
music Jack don't [ __ ] I lied I
actually like three saying somewhere you
really don't listen to them and I
promise that you would never like them
why would you also is classy a for
ticket I know but you so you only just
said you want to look at me back I was
like not no I how long he's been the way
I am with fires and tough guys you were
that way with those guys that's just the
fact you want to be it's so funny
because Brendan wants to be he went hang
out with him and just be like you know I
don't wear that outfit I can hang out
with them I don't wanna hang if you just
wanna be him no I can't sing like I
wanted me to silver you want to be that
guy not only be a singer I appreciate
Sony's we knew as long and see
yourselves million obviously I would
never knock him I'm just not a hater
like I don't hate on to anybody
especially when they'll be doing that
long I appreciate the talent yeah we do
you say you can't sing it well I believe
if you were drunk you would kiss him yep
in my heart I believe that if you
joke if you were drunk and you had a
little blowing or something I believe
that you would be like [ __ ] it I'll make
out with a guy I've never done it and
you do it here listen
yeah that sounds good
he's legit well hope anything well no I
don't hope you guys give me hope no I
hopefully get your approve my so a man
is cousin used to date the guy in his
band the drama so I know his music yeah
excited to make fun of him I was making
fun time that I listened him I was like
he's pretty legit have to make fun of
you now if he was like vanilla ice with
it for like two years that's like gave
me no I don't my favorite time when you
do it this long on that level God that
like people make fun of maroon 5 well
you know I have to say is this the guy
the guy won an Oscar as an actor and has
never stopped working on a high level
number one number one and how did he do
it just by being unique and different he
walks in and there's one Jared Leto
right it's also you can't just go we
talked about that we can pet with her
and on and on top of that he says he
decides he does music with his brother
he has a band and they sell I don't know
how many tickets what Kenny is you know
he's an arena act at least an arena act
30 seconds
Ching Google thirty Seconds to Mars huh
he's a ginormous there you go worldwide
travel all over the world private jets
so you got to give it out if you got to
the top of his field in two art forms
he's doing something he's special
now if he if you look like Michael
Rapaport you wouldn't give a [ __ ] who
sings then looks like Michael well
Danny's a fashionista guy who sells the
most tickets is the number one selling
just he's just a seasoned Geralyn
Geralyn
he's just an artist he's an artist throw
and throw that chair looks like [ __ ] gun
sells more takes anybody in the world
yeah but he is an artist
throw it throw oh yeah just a true
artist Joseph 1998 yeah I mean how do
you not love him how do you not look at
him he's I bet he's a little weird pride
drinks teenager blood to look that young
yeah
definitely hangs like a bat when he
sleeps yeah the international [ __ ] is
look at that say that ziggo dome what he
pees on the real that's an arena it's
not stadiums arena will he be bigger
internationally I think so well he's
just like a king yeah oh go up chin
teeth with says tour that looks
dangerously close to the Gracey tattoo
Brennan you got it you got it you got to
go where his house on his form no you
gotta goes house and go take it off I
wonder what that goes you see what says
torch in this work no no see the the top
we're all there there's a bunch of tacks
like crown paper see where says tour and
I'll see this where there is yes thanks
there we go I pretty much did that yeah
same stuff man a lot of people that
might be a that might be he does
festivals too though I'm surprised it
doesn't show what venues he's doing but
I do think he's bigger and
internationally yeah I do too look so
you that does look like Brian at yeah it
does I'll never be jared leto and that
hurts me that's not you letõs oh no no
no that's personally I just have great
hair and great bono who still sells
tickets that Dave Matthews Ben I'm sure
they still do it it was surprisingly
right deep sleep they've been around
forever I'm a Dave slave Dave slaves I
got it was that maybe your teeth went
from yellow to tan how'd you do it well
I don't have Quinton that's what
happened I don't have quick you can
literally put your mutant bite down on
something and it does the brushing for
you industrial strength power it's
basically got all kinds of it's got
sensitive vibrations with a built-in
timer it's gentle brushing for the
dentist recommended two minutes with
pervaded by dentists procreate by
dentists
yeah it's you need to form good habits
when it comes your teeth man all habits
clip starts at just $25 your first
refill free I get quip dot-com slash
fighter this is a simple way to support
the final kid
and have white teeth unlike Brian a nice
rushing brush heads they give you new
brushes every three months
crazy yeah it's this intuitive design
it's simple to use it comes with a
travel cap that doubles is a mirror
mount and you basically bite down on it
does all the brushing for you start
brushing the right way get clip right
now get clip qu IP comm / fighter you
guys that student loans refinancing them
with earnest could save you money or
lower your monthly payment bottom line
and it only takes two months to check
your rate online two minutes two months
too much it takes months
it takes for a lot of a lot of like
places take two months quit that two
minutes dude it takes your slug lens but
two minutes cuz you can't believe it
you can't believe it if you're still
paying the same rate your pain when you
graduated ARDS or you could reduce your
monthly payment and save big even if
you've already refinanced don't worry
about with today's low rate environment
most people can save by refinancing
again look Ernie offers customizable
loan terms no fees you can even combine
private and federal loans imagine having
one single monthly payment with one low
rate right if you qualify earnest offers
customization loan terms and no fees and
they're also rated nine point four out
of ten on Trustpilot so I always get the
support you need check this out already
refinance alone no problem you can still
be eligible to lower your interest rate
again start saving today foreign key
listeners get $100 cash bonus when you
refinance a student loan at earnest calm
/ fighter that's a hundred dollars cash
bonus when you refinance a student loan
at earnest calm / finder go to earnest
calm slash fighter today terms and
conditions apply Quito is we say Rancho
KEYT oh yes sir well when you're in
ketosis right it means your bodies were
not running off fat probably the best
way to lose weight I don't know for sure
they have a bluetooth-enabled breath
sensor did you're talking about hacks
ketosis yeah the most accurate
consistent the first time ever you see
user-friendly bluetooths breathalyzer an
app for healthy low carb and keto eating
what's up bro eight different level
of ketosis alone I said the need for you
know you urine strips her blood tests
not makes it easier just like speed a
keto kid super easy and it's accurate
it's on point and the keto breath sensor
is just $99 provides keto level readings
as well as access the QIOs upcoming food
products within the app for only $8 a
month users can subscribe to keto
premium for access to videos articles
recipes just a heart healthy judo
program restaurant guides you take your
skinny ass somewhere and you're like
what's keto you're gonna find out now
I'm skinny but you're shredded City City
you don't breast sensors in Premium
Subscription are available at getkey
TOCOM slash fighter that's GE t ke YT o
comm slash fighter the keto app is
available for both Android and iPhones
just search in the episode store for
Aikido that's KEYT o enter promo code
fighter for 20% off with Jared Leto
counter Jared there is Instagram I would
he got to in tournaments yeah
alright here we go so I don't know if
you guys saw this clip it went viral on
Friday because there was a school
shooting that happened earlier this year
in the spring around March in Portland
Oregon the footage just got released of
the coach who stopped the shooting he
actually was was the football coach at
the school and he also worked as a
security guard he was told that he had
to go to a classroom to escort a student
that was acting out to the guidance
counselor he showed up to the class and
asked that the student was there the
student had a shotgun underneath his
coat and he pulled it out very quickly
the security guard / coach assessed the
situation and he wrestled the kid for
the gun he got the gun away from the kid
as the other students ran out and
there's footage right here of him having
the shotgun passed off to another
teacher and then he hugs the child but
didn't if the kid says he was just gonna
shoot himself but anybody which I don't
that's what a lot of you have a trench
coat and a shotgun remember that's where
Leo DiCaprio did in basketball - well no
remember Columbine did that yeah in real
life well but carmine got the idea yeah
but the basketball that's what everyone
copies yeah [ __ ] this have you seen
that movie that scene yeah I mean Dylan
Klebold yeah that Columbine that the
Trent so I don't buy that he's just
gonna blow his own head off at the
school also you know yeah three months
probation yeah with uh he has to go
through a mental health program but he
only got three months probation he
bucked and when he did this he was
already 18 he's 19 now Wow so he was
technically like a yes it don't
suffering from mental what do you do
what you get lock him away can you do
there are professionals that probably
are able to assess this situation what I
want a [ __ ] powerful video though i
watch this he's holding on to him and
this kid needs help man
he needs help he's hysterical look I'm
Jeff I'm definitely not buying that he's
just gonna shoot himself though well you
can't buy that he was just gonna shoot
himself why would you come to the middle
of July night school why not always
assess the situation but this is a
desperate child desperate man yeah
desperate man yeah I don't know you do
when I already get three months parole
it's like [ __ ] what a powerful thing
though what about what a powerful thing
to hug something like that it really is
Jesus Christ that's it you know just
it's okay mom hmm that guy said that
guy's a [ __ ] hero to me I think
everybody is right what's that I think
everybody thinks he's a hero
yeah thank you thank you hey you could
be at the bottom of the ocean I gave the
hero everybody in a bank vault didn't
they'll find me state-of-the-art lock I
mean Dyke that kids lucky that Coach
didn't beat the [ __ ] out of two you know
you're lucky somebody else
what else he got men so a woman in San
Diego was living outside of her
workplace in her van she had two pet
rats who were mating like crazy and she
eventually got to the point where she
was housing 320 rats in her van directly
outside of her place of work must've
smelled pretty bad wait how'd you know I
get Black Plague or some [ __ ] don't
imagine there's urine they say they
still have whom all the bad [ __ ] still
rats there was an article about the like
traces of the bubonic plague being in
downtown LA
yes get ro oh yeah look at this though
that are cute apparently she was feeding
them and giving them ample amounts of
water and so this isn't an animal
cruelty case it's just them trying to
get I wonder what her boyfriend was
keeping too many rats Brennan are you
assuming she doesn't have a board yet
too many rats you had there are too many
rats here oh it's real quick let's go to
her husband what's his life thoughts on
this oh [ __ ] my son my son yesterday
he's got a bearded dragon it's a [ __ ]
you've had it for a while yeah yeah you
gotta feed it crickets
guess what when you go to the [ __ ]
aquarium when you go to Alan's aquarium
they have a shitload of big snakes my
son is eight he doesn't really you know
he's still you know he sees the worms
that dude drops a little baby mouse in
the [ __ ] cage this ball python buzz
if I send my idea he goes why is he
doing that at all and that's nice just
go scoot I'll shoot and rap song when I
go and my son goes oh yeah it's just
nature buddy he goes ah damn maybe
that's what he was he got I had to help
navigate through it then my other friend
decided to pick up I wasn't there to see
this when I got there she had picked up
a Goliath look up a Goliath tarantula a
bird Goliath bird-eating trans big boys
for a big boys yeah she picked that up
and got bit she got bit by a
I said don't pick her don't belong she
goes I have trash less it's filed God
pick that bad boy up and it gave her
coma dolls phangan now she said thing it
would have really hurt but he just gave
me a warning bite
now [ __ ] you hell [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm
not going near that why did she pick
that thing up cuz she's not afraid I
wouldn't go near that [ __ ] they
eat birds look at those [ __ ] fangs
she said if it wanted to bite me I would
have had to avoid it's not realize it's
fat yeah that's real that's a real
spider my again [ __ ] you MA oh my god
man where do they live in Australia of
course I live in South America
what does it say their home they live
everywhere a speedo Africa Australia the
parent eula the Goliath that on that one
though you know yeah says they're
probably South America Venezuela Brazil
French Guinea yeah all South America
deep rainforests Jesus Christ yeah
dear you know I thought your friend
deserve to get bit didn't you of course
don't be needy she was fine she was like
whatever I have to do non-venomous right
huh they're not venomous uh I don't
think so right they are not venomous but
you know they have giant [ __ ] teeth
dude hang I was never the kid that
wanted a pet uh weenie lighter or it's
me neither me neither
yeah do [ __ ] snakes I'm fine really you
deal with them harmless to humans yeah
but they still bite July by a toss
11 inches across biggest one on record
because it Daris - grace I thought the
biggest insect was the those spiders in
the desert others troops like holding
them up like those are desert camel
spiders yeah I thought those were the
biggest in the world I think I would say
a giant weight huh the largest spider
spider what's a giant Wetty fungus ass
like a grasshopper yeah disco life yeah
yeah I want to see the giant [ __ ] let
me see that [ __ ] you don't like that
better images
well well looks got big crap
I'll heat it the crab what crabs are
insect that they I was told that like
tarantula sees like soft-shell crab like
they were truly have the same time sure
people eat ranches yeah yeah to us you
just you got to burn their hair off I
would imagine I've seen them on sticks
yeah in we're at in somewhere in Asia oh
yeah Vietnam yeah you know I wish I had
it [ __ ] all these bugs you know I wish I
had cat it's a chicken sandwich do you
want more
yeah I bring me one of those I'm going
I'm going to glendale's do a BA I'm
downtown downtown hey come see me and
Brad this weekend 24 2015 6 that's why
I'm going to talk about the whole time
oh I'm going to Glendale
so is it near there it's where is it -
it's in Chinatown yeah way too long
Glendale do you pass by it and grab it
they're opening one up in Pasadena next
year but Brandon go get Miller yeah get
some of those cats I'll bring some next
week there's certain things like like if
I said to you dude go get me one of the
Sam she's gonna right now can you
imagine the disrespect oh I'd piss in
your mouth like what would it have dig
if I said Brent I'd piss in your imagine
I called you how serious I go hey dude
can you help me move I'm just hanging up
the phone that I can't [ __ ] wait Wow
so just wanted this time I got you guys
mild cuz I didn't know how well you guys
think you like my what's that well it's
mild medium high oh you're hot and then
did you win again huh
get me medium medium okay chin had
medium on Sonya yes I'm not hot give me
two of them cat get - they're huge
- they were that was the nice sandwich
I've ever had one of the best ever and
you had it cold because you guys did the
whole podcast and then had it it was
delicious I want oh my god so many
Philly cheesesteak out in Philly you did
I've been [ __ ] non-stop laughs dude
I don't feel good
you went off your diving so yeah just
Philly yeah head it's not good cuz I've
been are you dieting yo
yeah been on keto and then I was a coma
cheat on my diet while in Philly yeah so
you don't know alcohol no nothing I care
about Claudia I can just have whiskey oh
right here Oh Brian when you get older /
iya woke up you eat late
it's Friday let me know Brian welcome
Friday and my legs were my legs
especially my lower legs my tendons were
aching to the point where I look at me
yeah
fifty I know this was a weird virus or
something I was like what is wrong with
me my knees maybe what no I might be
getting arthritis I think I might be
really [ __ ] up
get some matter today fine yeah take
some fish oil yeah maybe really just
kind of you know it's father time dude
it might be father time but I'm knocking
on the knees bro probably right not
still playing tennis are you yeah not
really
tennis tennis a couple days ago pray
that you're right
fifty and tennis well why why because
when I wake up I can't I I have to warm
my feet up
me and Jimmy Burke whose ancient we're
talking about how yet we have to warm
our feet up like a [ __ ] do Sasori
balls before I get on the ground dude
yeah if you break into my house at night
though
I'm gonna be in some trouble I'm gonna
be walking like I'm on stilts
I got wooden feet in any case the old
wood soil dude I do right yeah and these
chicken sandwiches what's the fries like
tag I don't want to talk about your
names what's the next [ __ ] current
event god I wanna [ __ ] he's freaking out
it's like porn for you dude does he look
good to the first phrase that go ready
to sprinkle on the weekends they do a
chicken sandwich with waffles I hate
that [ __ ] you don't like this sweet
table you can't [ __ ] stand what
people makes chicken and waffle nothing
drives me more nuts
I never when they do like donuts and
chicken get the [ __ ] out of here man
just do it
II like this what does she got where is
it jared leto so this okay so a
Australian airline in Qantas last Friday
they did the very first direct flight
from New York to Sydney it took 20 hours
right now they're trying to see what
FEX having such a long flight takes on
the crew as well as passengers to see if
this is going to be a viable choice in
the future because that the lung cuz
right now 19 hours I think as long as
from New Jersey to New Zealand's the
longest flight can take is it direct
yeah I think so that's the long as you
can take this is pretty this is how many
oxygen into the cabin that's the first
thing because the oxygen air gets
recycled it's just such you know Jay
flew to Singapore some [ __ ] where
everyone in Asia and he said that the
way they deal with jet lag they recycle
the air every 10 minutes in the cabin
just so I think if it helps you [ __ ]
yeah
but only certain air like he did like he
flew I forget what he flew cuz you're
true you're breathing in terrible air
because everybody's like the hairspray
and all that it's just all ha too bad
Martin you know people pardon me from
Jersey that's what Brno 18 18 20 I think
it's the longest flight you take see if
it's the only flight now I think from
Brazil to Japan that's halfway across
that's 28 hours
long flight to take in the world
Singapore 22 hours to new work I went
there Singapore to Newark Newark yeah
let's let's tell my [ __ ] brother I've
done that that's what Jay went to
Singapore there's a
Thailand waka and uh Doh Doh hah
I went from New York I went from tie
lines in New York oh my god though worse
dude [ __ ] Austria from LA the [ __ ]
beast yeah how many hours is at 14-14
Africa Atlanta then it's 14 from there
right South Africa was was 16 [ __ ] you
slam my dick in the door I can't do it
that's the same going to venom Hall for
15 hours and 15 minutes wait
but Lausanne city takes close to 17
hours there you go
17 hours great great place it's a beast
why don't you guys got what did we have
go
I was just looking at that myself what
was that from Greg Hardy I always
wondered like you know the pictures of
the girlfriend that got beat up they
weren't what because I wanted to see how
bad it was I heard snow and then I'll be
honest it didn't seem as crazy as I
imagined
Oh heat you do a lot more damage I know
so when I saw this it just and different
pictures make it look worse depending on
how they do the contrast it's not good
it's not good for sure I thought she
would be like that'd be like real
looking Rihanna hiss yeah feet but she
also attacked him I believe so I don't
know I bet the scratchy got her no it's
a long time ago I was just curious she
brought that up
that was for well the belt oh those yeah
but I didn't I just chose not to do it
this one right again he just fought Oh
carry on this is Lady gaga
falling it's not even her fault really
it's a fangirl she asked for a fan to
pick her up the photo Jos her fan to
come up on stage and the fan decided to
pick her up because she put her leg on
his council high so he picks her up and
it falls off yeah no no what a night you
got to see this it's actually it was not
a regular fall it's actually a pretty
bad fall I'll show you the other day so
he just picks her up right okay look how
bad that hard fall why is the spotlight
then down to the ground
[Applause]
say it again why is the guy yoke I know
it's bad
he was weblogs [ __ ] [ __ ] she knows
now what is a bad angle - and there she
is
oh my god the whole crowd yeah kind of
not - biggest [ __ ] what they call a
month little monsters she's probably the
biggest fan yeah [ __ ] Easter there she
went on with the concert
right booty but she says she's an
incredible amount of pain right now yeah
it's like [ __ ] yeah yeah after you fall
off like that
oh man I thought you know I'm just gonna
leave I [ __ ] man I'm just gonna get out
of here
have you guys seen Miguel I try to do a
jump on the VMAs and then land on that
family you know yeah yeah he he tried to
jump from stage to stage he almost made
it and then a woman's head just gets in
between his crotch and her head lands on
the stage says he eats [ __ ] we got kids
two girls in the fitnah face banana not
purpose not on purpose which towards the
end of the performance and he just plays
it off hey you two grab the girl like oh
yeah let's but was it her
no it wasn't is the one down the yeah
the one who got hit is still on the
floor that lady was trying to help her
boom
Miguel thought it was her and he's not
missing a beat
did you do did she break her face oh my
god the aftermath of her face was
horrendous is there pictures yeah if you
look it up there are photos I think he
then paid for all of her medical bills
how to do that poor girl probably
Grandal wife is sick they're relaxing
but yeah okay Miguel but also don't jump
from stage the stage in those tight-ass
pants dude he really thought he was
gonna make it to looks so confident
that's a comfy deep dude that's a beam
no that's like a stunner on your baby
look at her face turn
she does kind of melt away then she got
I mean he landed on her goddamn head
I've seen bread broken my heart man in
this [ __ ] on P I could have broken her
neck you're an idiot
I wonder what happened to her she got
she died we all suit two years she
weighed in two years
well she's probably [ __ ] up I hope
she's okay so - why Cindy sighs an Asian
bro
oh Jesus hi Brittish she looked black
hmm well hopefully she's all right
God that would suck men Lisa Miguel
small I guess well small dude that's not
gonna help
there's a bunch of Cindy sighs you only
want to got kicked in the face uh-huh
well shut up - Cindy sighs what else you
got this is not that new anymore but
Will Smith did this little thing with
the shoe did you guys see this so check
out this video what colors do you guys
see Oh
I've saw this aha min ago I didn't see
both but predominantly seen pink I see
pink easy I see blue I learned about it
now but before I saw I saw gray I saw
straight-up granblue I see pink and YC I
see a grand pink and white shoe I can't
wait what does this mean
brain is dominant you will see
combination of pink and white color if
your left brain is dominant I guess I'm
left brain wait I don't think that's
even Chanel either maybe they just wrote
that but it's when I learned about it it
seemed like it was taken in like dark
light or black light or something yeah
the flash just like yeah and once you
know it's pink no that's not true Chan
you're wrong [ __ ] her I see in both
ways now no you don't I swear to God I
see a change a change
wait what's insane you either see pink
or you see gran Korean what are you
sayin he said ha someone explain it like
someone took it what it means is that
domina which makes me high life no I
would be why cuz artists tend to be
lying I thought Dargis is right no
artists is right right creativity isn't
it it's right yeah Ryan's both google it
yeah I know it is a way but so is that
true though but I don't know no I don't
think it is probably made it up the
explanation just typed in the right side
I was gonna say the break yeah right put
him branded it's similar to otherwise
you know how do you click that one viral
the yeah knee earlier that three is the
right piece the theory is that other
left brain right brain mean that one
side of their brains
yeah right analytical on methodical in
your thinking maybe you're resetting
your levy yet ready yeah you really any
more creative or artistic your thought
I'd I tend to be more right brained I
believe we got that left right by I'm
very analytical I don't think well who
knows what that thing with that picture
I don't know if you see it as a
different color and you're saying it was
cuz of maybe the flashy used it's
probably no you're obviously your brain
is depending on how you see things yeah
I see grain I do not see pink that's
amazing I don't think you see that's
amazing alright what other things in the
world there is with flash and darkens
damn it it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter the tri-c's no matter what he
says a bad picture yeah no I totally saw
gray and blue when I first saw it but
once I heard it was like a flash then I
started seeing the color I know you just
you that's just weird
I could totally see it speak now but
before i sees what brennan sees is that
that image on the left what we see is
that yeah that's that's the point do you
see two different images Brendan or you
see only well see two different images
but the one Will Smith put on the right
that's still a pink shoe yeah okay does
this look a little bit more gradient
than this one or do they look example
let's take a shitty picture on the right
yeah so that's how I learned about still
pink well I didn't see the peak in the
beginning that's all I'm saying
yeah I didn't see the pink and then once
I knew was pink I saw pink okay have you
guys seen this rise or shine thing with
Kylie Jenner
it's I don't know why it's so funny but
it's super funny it's just I guess she
was doing a tour of her apartment or her
history yes sir office space there you
go
and then the cameraman was following her
and then she saw it she has a place for
her baby to sleep and then let me get
the perfect video here hopefully this is
it going it's not very like mom is
anyways there's a bunch of different
remixes and stuff to shine everyone's
clown and honor the Biron yeah yeah she
even climbed on herself she's coming out
with merch for ya she is right yeah
she's coming out with rise and shine
hoodies of course and Ariana Grande did
it you're not getting this at all
alright that's fine it's just super
funny to me and then they had another
one
hold on this is the last one of this
this man still thinking about the shoe
no no I'm just thinking about um I was
like she did have weight that kid uh
pretty abruptly has brightful I was
saying yeah that was little I haven't
seen that yet what's next this is in
Dublin and this guy would guess he
passed away and I guess he was like a
prankster to his family funny I know did
I play this one no I didn't right hand
please don't yet okay okay all right
though all right what's clapping
yep how does funeral I've been to some
didn't like it for young people
anyhow it's a long video so he was just
knocking on the coffin saying let me out
let me out the way he was ill from
something what he was a yeah well older
yeah
funny though there he is oh no here's
our old school man I feel like you're
gonna mix it up I went to a Jewish
funeral for my friend Karen and we had
to put rocks everybody would put like
you dumped a rock up you know onto the
everybody and I shoveled some dirt and
there was ice [ __ ] in the day no it's if
I say it's gonna sound like I'm just
making it up well he was huge rock on
the shovel or not I went okay I think it
thought it sound like it cracked the
fella it sounded like he went Keith I
thought I got broken oh it was so bad
but there were like Jesus I mean kid
okay I remember the the [ __ ] the
rabbi was next to her sister or yeah and
said something sister maybe or maybe
even her mother and said it's a
catastrophe this is a catastrophe and
all we can do is take it one hour at a
time one day at a time if you can't do
one day at a time we'll take it an hour
of time oh did she die young yeah she
don't know but I never forgot it I was
like watching I was watching uh she was
my acting class for years and my
neighbor she was four houses down beige
but died from they don't know cuz she
died if she died of some kind of a toxic
exposure of some poisoning or something
he was [ __ ] weird and they didn't go
to the doctor until it was too late they
were trying to do the alternative
medicine thing Andy Kaufman stuff yeah
we'll just end it on this this is from
shark tank it's a pretty sure this guy's
pitch coke yeah look at it look at how
this guy does this thing and
how everyone reacts and inhales slowly
but deeply you which is the strongest
one they're all similar intensity which
is the most popular tropical is our
bestseller oh this is like the pneumonia
that lifters use now are your football
players yeah or fighters damn I'm down
with it sounds nice
so what is boom boom it's just like I
look like coffee but you're just a
little hit with your nose a little boost
of energy the inhale all right
I don't know I got a run kids all right
go for it let's do it man that's in this
it's good stuff yeah yes no I'm not 24
25 26 Bray Improv on there this coming
weekend is Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday we got Brian Cowen and Brendan
Schaub and friends basically for this
charity at the comedy stores to show up
on the 27th instead of 8 is the 8
o'clock this Thursday Pasadena Icehouse
I got Fahim Anwar
I got Whitney Cummings Derrick post in
one show only ten pm pasady in the ice
house shopping friends and then November
Dallas 14th through the 16th and then I
end November Salt Lake City wise guys
that's twenty first twenty third and
then December Kansas City New Jersey
bananas Thursday Friday then I'm at the
big casino in Atlantic City that's
Saturday on the 14th get your tickets
tea fat K calm this is the fight of the
distractor kid Wow yeah that's not as
Lord